[Music]
can you read in the car if so consider
yourself pretty lucky for about
one-third of the population looking at a
book while moving along in a car or boat
or train or plane quickly makes them
sick to their stomach but why do we get
motion sickness in the first place well
believe it or not scientists aren't
exactly sure the most common theory has
to do with mismatched sensory signals
when you travel in a car your body's
getting two very different messages your
eyes are seeing the inside of the
vehicle which doesn't seem to be moving
meanwhile your ear is actually telling
your brain you're accelerating wait your
ear yeah your ear actually has another
important function besides hearing in
its innermost part lies a group of
structures known as the vestibular
system which gives us our sense of
balance and movement inside there are
three semicircular tubules that can
sense rotation one for each dimension of
space and there are also two hairline
sacs that are filled with fluid so when
you move the fluid shifts and tickles
the hairs telling your brain whether
you're moving horizontally or vertically
with all these combined your body can
sense which direction you're moving in
how much you've accelerated even at what
angle so when you're in the car your
vestibular system correctly senses your
movement but your eyes don't see it
especially if they're glued to a book
the opposite can happen to say you're
sitting in a movie theater and the
camera makes a broad sweeping move this
time it's your eyes I think you're
moving while your ear knows that you're
sitting still but why does this
conflicting information have to make us
feel so terrible scientists aren't sure
about that either but they think that
there's an evolutionary explanation you
see both fast moving vehicles and video
recordings will only exist in the last
couple of centuries barely a blink in
evolutionary time for most of our
history there just wasn't that much that
could cause this kind of sensory mix-up
except for poisons and because poisons
are not the best thing for survival our
bodies evolved a very direct but not
very pleasant way to get rid of whatever
we might have eaten that was causing the
confusion this theory seems pretty
reasonable but it leaves a lot of things
on explained like why women are more
affected by motion sickness than men or
why passengers get more nauseous than
drivers another theory suggests that the
cause may have more to do with the way
some unfamiliar situations make it
harder to maintain our natural body
posture studies have shown that being
immersed in water or just changing your
stance can greatly reduce the effects of
motion sickness but again we don't
really know what's going on we all do
know some of the more common remedies
for car queasiness looking at their eyes
enjoying gum taking over-the-counter
pills but none of these are totally
reliable nor can they handle really
intense motion sickness
and sometimes the stakes are far higher
than just not being bored during a long
car ride at NASA where astronauts are
hurtled into space at 17,000 miles per
hour motion sickness is a serious
problem so in addition to researching
the latest space-age technologies NASA
also spends a lot of time trying to
figure out how to keep astronauts from
vomiting up they're carefully prepared
space rations much like understanding
the mysteries of sleep or curing the
common cold motion sickness remains one
of those seemingly simple problems that
despite amazing scientific progress we
still know very little about perhaps one
day the exact cause of motion sickness
will be found and with it a completely
effective way to prevent it but that day
is still on the horizon
[Music]